hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 16 of network chat
programming so today we're going to talk
about receiving packets and this is
probably going to be a bit of a bit of a
longer episode here because what we're
going to be doing is actually testing
this receiving so in other words what we
will do today is connect our server to
our client via a network well in this
case via just this computer but this
will actually work over over LAN ovarium
over any kind of network as long as of
course firewalls and ports are unblocked
as needed okay so how do we do this so
we've got this receive method in server
this is the this is the the server class
right and in server we've got this
method called receive and this is where
we're going to be doing all of our
receiving stuff so what do we need to do
well as you probably recall from the
previous episode we have this socket
object right and what is that that's a
Datagram socket that's bound to a
specific port we can send and receive
data through that port via that socket
so to receive all we need to do really
is call socket dot receive okay now now
when we receive something we actually
receive a packet of data we have to
create that packet of data so that we
can store the information or the packet
that we receive so to do that we simply
go ahead and we create a first of all a
byte a byte array which will contain all
of our data that we receive again I'm
just going to I'm just going to limit it
to to one kilobyte here 1,024 bytes and
I'll create a Datagram a packet and I'll
call it packet and that'll be equal to
new data round packet and remember we're
receiving so we need to care about
release data which is where we're going
to store our data and data dot length
because that's the amount of data that's
being stored and of course by calling
data we're referring to this byte array
let's quickly import diagram packet
because we haven't used it in this class
yet and it will go socket dot receive
packet okay and what that does is it
actually shoves all of our data that
we'll receive into this packet which in
turn puts it into this
data array so now if we just try and
cash this entire process I like to I
like to just move this sum if we just uh
fall we could move this try up here but
really it's not it's not 100% necessary
so I'm going to leave it out here but
after that after that we needed well
preferably win an issue but we should we
do something with this with this byte
array which is now full of bytes now
because the information that we're going
to be receiving is primarily going to be
strings what we could do is simply
create a string and I'll call it a I
guess I'll just call it string and we'll
actually set that equal to new string
yeah and the parameter here is going to
be packet dot packet whoops packet dot
get data okay and that actually returns
a byte array so it kind of does it
basically what happens here right is um
we create a new packet soccerpro receive
shoves all of that all of our data into
the packet and what packet does is
actually populate this array which we
can get by popping up packet get data so
now that we've got this right what we've
got is some data okay and what will
happen is as soon as we receive this
because this is a while writing loop
it'll wait until it gets some kind of
information some kind of data over the
network when it does it's going to of
course basically pop that data into this
packet here and then we're going to get
the data into a string format okay and
what happens is that completes obviously
so it goes back to the start of this
while running loop as as long as running
is true and it goes down and it gets
down to receiving it waits and then it
receives something and then it continues
down puts it into a string and then it
goes back to the side and keeps doing
that as long as we're running okay so
let's do something cool with this let's
just let's just print it out to the
console that's the coolest thing to
possibly do so we'll just print out
string okay so all we've done is we've
created a new string based on the data
that we get and we've printed it out to
the console brilliant so that's really
pretty much it okay if we go into a if
we go into seven men so where we start
our server this stuff is all the stuff
is all working I believe I don't think
we did anything
it wasn't working here so will this
server that we start on the port yep
that's correct and you know what let's
say when a server is started let's be
nice here and let's actually uh as long
as it does get started let's just system
app dot on fact let's do this in a
students in the wrong method right so
after we set running it equal to true
system dot out dot print line server
started on port plus port okay and
that's pretty much it right that'll just
tell us that the server has actually
indeed been started on this port and
there hasn't been any kind of exception
because if there is we should really
return from the method after printing
the stacktrace so we shouldn't start the
server anyway because what will happen
is if that if this does actually
generate an exception what will happen
is it'll simply go down to and to run
here and it'll actually start that
thread and it'll start trying to you
know solve this while running lope and
there's no need if the service failed to
start so it's a good idea to return here
okay so that's looking pretty good
again we're actually only at five
minutes which is good as well I thought
this will take longer um we'll talk
about managing next next episode so now
that we've done this received method
what we should do now is ideally test it
so inside client I want to go back to
client or Java which is our client-side
what we've got in client is a bunch of
GUI stuff of course but what we've got
as well is this send method so what I'm
going to do is basically as soon as we
connect perhaps so we open in connection
here we don't really have any kind of
this is also why differentiating them is
a good idea by the way because we don't
really have any kind of like you know
loops or anything but just to be just be
really cool here when we when we where's
our littler text so send right send is
our little a method here that
essentially sends a math the message so
when we print the message out to the
console yeah let's also just simply send
and what we need here is a byte of data
all we really need to do here is just go
to the actual message that
want to convert which is message and all
we have to do is type in message dot get
bytes again and that will just return a
byte array of our message of our string
which is which is awesome so now we've
done that everything should be pretty
much good so what will happen is when we
sell this client we of course give it
the address of the server and what it
will try to do is send the server our
message yep brilliant another thing we
should do as well is when we actually
start the you see this attempting
connection to what we should do is we
should also try and send as it's doing
that you know we should send let's see
let's just send a string such as you
know um mmm
what if I call it a watch tyah well I
guess we'll go name what's makers the
strings will have to
so string connection equals aha name
connected from and then we'll type in
the address and then we might pop a
little just the poor thing here as well
okay so that's our connection and then
we'll go connection will send a
connection dot get bytes okay and that
is that's pretty much it so let's try
and do this okay let's try and actually
launch the server and see if it
intercepts that pack of data and prints
it to the console because what it should
do is just print whatever it receives
all right so here's our console over
here I'm going to try and fit this in
for you guys somehow I'm just going to
drag it up here it gets a bit uh it gets
a bit hard to do this with the amount of
screen space that we have just because I
obviously you guys want me to zoom in a
bit to the code so you can see it but
here's the console you guys should be
able to see that well so what I'll do is
I'll start the server okay and I do that
simply by if we go to serve it up main
and I can do okay hang on first of all
let's see yeah so okay I receive until
okay let's go to seven main and so let's
say over here if I go through debug
configure
versions real quick so we can see what
port was starting it on I think is that
one okay triple a well will change to
add one line to just because that's how
I roll
that's usually my go-to port number so
we're starting a new main server here
with a with a port here and that's of
course in turn starting a new server so
let's go to server domain because this
is the one that has the main method and
let's simply uh run that I guess or
terminate straight away so we've
probably screwed something up here yep
what we've done is uh we never started
this run thread so make sure we call Ron
dot start to actually start this this
ron method which of course will run our
ron method this run thread which will
run our run method probably shouldn't
call the thread run that's really mail
for so let's go back to server man which
is the one with our with our main class
and we'll just hit a we'll just stop
that okay so what we have now is is
currently running and you can see that
by the fact that doesn't say terminated
here also there is a little terminate
red button here we've started a server
on port a at one nine two brilliant so
it started and it's actually just
waiting for packets right now so what
we'll do is while this has started I'm
actually going to go into the login job
which is our other program which of
course has its own main method so now
since I'm going to instance I'm inside
this I can just hit the debug button
again and it will actually just launch
the GUI now one of the things that's
happened here is the console as you can
see has actually changed to the to this
right to this login screens console and
to get around that what we can do is we
can actually open a new window so if we
go window show view and then debug which
isn't even here so we'll have to click
other and go to debug and debug hit okay
and this will actually have you can see
that we've got two applications running
here and this is really useful as well
this view of probably take a minute just
to explain this as well this has all of
our different threads listed as well as
application so you can see here's server
main we've got two applications
currently running server man which is
our server and login which is our our
client so if we go on to on the server
man you can actually see the threads
that are running so this again is the
default thread that runs and that's the
destroyed Java Virtual Machine thread
that's actually what what actually tells
the program
to stop so after you request for it to
stop either by quitting closing whatever
you do terminating the application this
is what actually ends the process okay
manage and receive are the current two
threads that are running so if we go
into a server you see that we of course
called manage clients and receive and
both receive and manage clients have
their all their own while running loop
which is indeed in their own threads
this is why we named the threads as well
because if we do named threads like that
what that allows us to do is um is
actually read them here you can see
that's one close has managed throughout
this one's has receive threads with
where problems we can diagnose them
login only has a lock and actually has a
bunch of threads and the reason it's got
a bunch of threads is because we're
running the AWT which is the abstract
window toolkit that is the actual GUI
okay that's this window because we've
created a window nocturnal application
you can see how much I'm like it's a lot
heavier way and that's because it's
listening for things like if we close it
and do all that all that good stuff so
that's how this works now what we can do
is if we actually click on the server
main here and go back to the console you
can see the console is indeed our server
main console again so you can use debug
to switch between applications if I
click on login again you can see it's
the login java application so we'll
switch over to seven-man go to console
and here's our port so we'll login okay
so yarn will be our name localhost will
be our IP address because we're
referring to this computer you can also
type in 127.0.0.1 which is localhost but
was poppin localhost because it's
probably easy for you guys to her to
remember so 8 1 9 2 is the port will hit
login ok so we've got a bunch of errors
here which is kind of good in a way ok
it's good because clearly the server
received some packets in fact we got an
actually I don't think that was all that
was oh that's interesting
yeah ok so this is one of the problems
that I actually wanted to talk to you
guys about now server is still fun right
but but our application isn't ok
application is a thing the crash there's
actually a perfect example of what I
wanted to touch on let's keep our server
running nothing is wrong with the server
ok if we go to log
you'll notice that what I did here is I
actually logged in with a particular
port now that's an issue okay and I
wanted to clearly illustrate that only
thing anyone picked up on that ever
which is which you know I'm not
expecting you to but I'm in port okay
what we do here is in this is in the
client class of course where please
start a new data Graham socket at a
specific port that's a problem because
that tells it okay start a server pretty
much of that port it doesn't really say
start a server at that port it says
occupy that port now we've already got
something bound to 8 1 9 2 yeah we
already got something it bound to 8 1 9
2 and that is the actual server so how
can we how can we take that that port if
it's already taken we can't write that's
important possible another one person
actually tweeted meaning any asked is it
possible to you know with security in
Java is it actually possible to to
hijack a port in a way will not really
hijack a port but use can another
application intercept packets that are
bound are to a server based on specific
port and the answer is pretty much know
right there are of course there's I'm
not gonna go into hacking and stuff but
the idea is it's not actually possible
to just simply if if you've got if
you've got an application that's using a
specific port you can't actually create
another application that uses that same
port it won't let you okay and the
reason you won't let you is because it's
already occupied like there's actually
like the hardware allocates
a hardware allocates although I'm not
gonna get too much into this because
ports are layer 3 I think a layer for
ports are a different ball game
altogether they're pretty much the
highest level of them as far as the as
far as the network layer of stuff goes
anyway the point is that we can't start
and we can't start this diagram socket
on this port because already taken so
what I recommend you guys do is simply
delete that parameter all together
ok you guys might be like ok well then
why is this port parameter even here and
there's a big reason for that right
there isn't this poor parameters here we
can actually get rid of it in open
connection because we don't need to for
open connection but the reason it's in
it's here in this class is because that
port is the destination port of where we
want to send our daughter
right the server runs on a specific port
if we go down here you can see in send
and I'll have to a let me just stir okay
over here in send ah that's clearly not
yet at all okay in send and we'll go to
our actual send method you can see that
we actually destined this packet for a
specific IP address and a port now that
port is where we send the packet to so
that's why we need to enter the packet
when we launch the geo why because um
that port is actually the location it's
it's the service port right it's where
we want to send the packet to we want to
send to us visit to a specific address
and we want to send it to a specific
port because address is important to go
together because of course an address
the server might be running multiple
applications and we want to target we
want to send this packet of data
specifically to the Cherno chat
application which we've given the port
number 8 1 9 2 so anything that gets
sent to a 1 9 2 will get picked up by on
this server ok so now that we've changed
that ok our servers still running again
what I did change that just in case you
missed that through all Maya through all
my explanations what we did change them
was we simply removed the port from here
so there used to be a parameter here
called port we've gotten rid of that ok
so what we're doing now if you mouse
over and look at the Java doc we are
constructing a Datagram so going to
binds it to any available port ok now
what we can do and you guys might be
like you smart cookies out there might
be like I'm never saying that again
you guys might you guys out there might
be like well ok if we don't even know
what Paul we're binding it to don't we
need to somehow send the server that
port so that it can then reply to us and
send data back to the correct port if
we're running a random port that's
available how does the server know where
to send the packet to and I'm glad you
asked because we're going to talk about
that probably next time but the idea is
that when we receive this packet of data
here there is actually an application
sorry there's actually a method called
packet get address ok that's actually
useful useless I just realized packet
get port ok because we already know the
address of the I actually know we don't
that's a good point we can use packet
get address and packet get port and then
I'll actually get the are be the source
port and address because of course when
packets of Joliette sent over now
work by UDP TCP whatever not only the
destination is included in the header
the source address and port are also
included ok enough talking I hope you
guys understood that you might want to
watch that a few times to really get it
if you want to get this and this stuff
will be actually implemented in the game
programming series so if you're on the
integrating video games instead of all
these network applications I still
highly recommend you guys to really get
this ok this was kind of an in-depth
video I should have probably gone that
far but you can see this is still
running because it doesn't say turn 8 it
and this is still here so what I'll do
is in login I'll start be bad login
application again I'll switch over to
debug and I will click on server main so
I um
so I returned back here on to the the
console view for the server I'll type in
a yarn localhost and a 1 9 2 and that of
course is the destination port and I'm
going to try and log in and you can see
when I hit login right this server says
yarn connected from localhost
at 192 brilliant right and over here if
I type something like hey what's up hit
enter or send it'll actually appear here
on the server ok
so what's up bros my name is the Cherno
i'll hit send and here it is it appears
on the server ok
so what we've done now right what we
have done now is we've actually sent a
packet of data from one application to
the other over network ok so that's
going to wrap up this episode I may do a
little cool vlogging kind of
demonstration of actually showing you
how it travels from one computer to the
other tell me let me know if you guys
want that it probably just going to be a
ridiculously short video that um I'm I
don't know but the point is I hope you
guys really enjoy this at this episode
of network share programming it's
probably the most in-depth one we've had
so far and really what the series is
going to kind of continue in the spirit
of but if you do enjoy the episode place
with the like button again if we hit 200
likes we'll get one video per day 300
likes 2 videos per day ok so it's up to
you guys and I'll see you guys next time
good